hey
quick question for you you ever look at
a person's baby pictures and wonder how
people go from being small to well big i
mean i yes i get it people grow up but
here i'm thinking more on the level of
the atoms and molecules that make up the
body because a i'm a scientist and
that's kind of what we do and then also
b because you know after all all the
changes we see on these larger scales
are just reflections of very many
changes occurring on the molecular scale
right and so
if you think about it that way then it's
likely reasonable to assume that because
the adult's body is bigger it has more
molecules and or larger molecules than
the baby's body and so this means that
there are some molecules in this baby
and those molecules are interacting and
combining with some other source of
molecules in the world in order to
become this adult and generally speaking
the source of those molecules is going
to be our diet aka our food and to kind
of understand this we can actually make
a comparison here between food and wood
so what i mean by that is that the
molecules and food interact with the
molecules on our bodies in two primary
ways
the first is as a source of molecular
building blocks or in other words
molecules the body can use to build new
structures and the second is going to be
as a source of molecules for fuel much
like a campfire or firewood right like
what we have here
but in order to understand how and why
this can happen we need to briefly
discuss the molecular basis of food
right so what are the molecules in food
let me introduce you all right because
generally speaking food is made up of
these three classes of molecules
first up are fats
then we've got sugars
and finally some protein
i'd imagine some of these sound
reasonably familiar
these molecules are made basically from
just a few elements right so this is
color-coded and the gray balls are
carbon the white ones are hydrogen those
are the big ones right so most of life's
molecules are made mostly of carbon and
hydrogen but we've also got oxygen here
and red and nitrogen and blue those are
the other two big ones
and every now and then we'll also find
small amounts of some other elements
like this sulfur here in yellow
but the super interesting part here is
that these are actually the same exact
elements that make up most of the cells
in your body right so you may notice on
this right hand side the same colors is
what we have on the left
right so this is where the whole
molecular lumber thing comes in
our cells can take food and break it
down into small building blocks and then
use those building blocks in order to
build new structures in our body right
so this is how we grow right this is how
babies become adults turns out we
actually are what we eat it's pretty
amazing
all right but before we get too excited
let's bring it in right so let's switch
gears for a second here to talk about
the other side of things because i told
you before that food is like wood
and we can use wood to build new
structures sure but when we need to we
can also burn wood to get energy right
so we can start a campfire and if we do
we know that we're going to get some
energy in the form of light right we'll
get some energy in the form of heat and
maybe some other things like sound
and food is actually the same way right
so we can take those same food molecules
that we broke down before to get
building blocks and instead use them as
fuel to generate cellular energy
and then we can use that cellular energy
to fuel all of the building that we just
talked about
and likewise if our cells work together
which they do they can use this energy
to do things like running thinking and
all the other things that we humans do
all right
let's step back just one more time
because what we'll see is that these two
processes that we've just described
right so food is lumber and food is fuel
actually explains so much of life right
so this is not just us every living
thing on this planet is doing this right
so you feed your dog to fuel his or her
molecular construction projects as well
so right there and then we've already
kind of answered our question from
before which reminder was how do people
go from small to big right so what's
happening is that this baby becomes an
adult by eating food milk formula gushy
stuff i don't know whatever babies eat
and some of the molecules in that food
will be used as fuel to generate energy
and then some of that energy will be
used to combine food molecules with
molecules in the baby to build up a
larger baby aka an adult
all right i hope that helps let's wrap
it here see you in the next one